(gunshot)
- That's pretty good for your first time.
- Oh I think we should fair very well.
I'm very well versed in rifles, shotguns,
pistols, sniper rifles,
all type of weaponry.
- Never shot a gun before
and kind of scared.
These arms weren't made for gun shooting.
These arms were made for hugs.
- You know, I come from
Kansas City, Missouri.
And mostly all my family's all farmers.
So I'm kind of used to shooting a shotgun
or different guns as a kid.
- I'm looking forward to the gun range
portion of this competition.
I think it's going to be a
great chance at retribution.
(video game music)
- Go!
(gunshots)
- He's dead.
- We set up two targets at 25 meters
and we did two to the face, two
to the face, two to the face
switching between the targets.
Two rounds in this targets,
two rounds in the left target,
and then two rounds in the right target.
Oh, in the face.
In the face.
Shoot them in the face!
- In the face!
- It's all about the face.
- Go!
He's dead!
- Probably a little faster
would have been better,
but the shots are really good.
- These guys did an outstanding job.
A lot better than I
anticipated they would.
- Jadey's never shot in his life,
so he did really well considering
that it was his first time.
- The difference is
between us playing a game
against you guys and
how much of a difference
between skill levels on
that compared to this
was not nearly as great.
- I was just thinking don't (censored) up.
I wasn't thinking "Don't (censored)".
There wasn't really too much mess up.
It was more just like
I was just thinking take your time
and don't be hasty.
Don't try to look cool or
something for the cameras
because I was like I don't have time
to mess up and hit the ceiling
and let shrapnel hit us or something.
I don't know.